[Musique]
alors bonjour la planète on veut avoir
une photo de groupe
ça coûte cher canada qui était bon dans
les nouveaux studios il est 11 heures 11
minutes et 30 secondes heure de montréal
on a mis 20 secondes à s'ajuster parce
qu'il fait froid d'avancé pour ça et
puis parce que bien sûr ses nouveaux
studios alors c'est j'espère que vous
avez apprécié au cours des prochaines
années
on a de nouveau su encore dans je pense
neuf mois parce qu'on va changer
d'édifices des choses qu'on va garder
cette facture générale chabrette avait
près la même chose avec décors alors les
originaux et là bonjour jean marie
chauvet la roja stéphane alléchante
halde chandeigne avait un quatrième tome
40 camps très bien du nom de mon papa ah
oui voilà monsieur quand on est il si
stéphane vous avez aussi il manque
quelqu'un belle et là à trois pieds en
maître se fait un matelot même être
quelqu un peut plus elle mesure quand
même un peu plus que maintenant elle
gérait 1 83 elle a sensiblement la même
taille que moi c'est un mètre 80 on
pourrait la longe et disent ils
marie-claude bonjour marie quand ima
bonjour tout le monde
est ce que voulait faire jouer comme ça
qu'on vous voit en images ce que c'est
possible aujourd'hui doit en images mais
ça va être difficile mais bon c'est tout
caméra ce uniquement pour vous en avez
une pour vous nous on le transfère 16
cameron alors que phil la cuisine on va
vers le sujet des missions vous après ce
qu'ils veulent en compagnie de
marie-claude qui de marie claude rester
à la caméra parce qu'on vous allez
participer ne connaissait pas le sujet
des missions même si vous êtes le numéro
un vous presser sur le bouton très bien
merci
on regarde son ensemble d'imagés on
devait une sujet démission aujourd'hui
dès que vous pensez sur la bonne piste
vous lever la même barre aux crises
auxquelles les accidents c'est sûr qu'on
est à l'hébreu chose qui est intéressant
c'est la vidéo de 0,1 qu'on aimerait
avoir un je pense qu'on voit là viraux
de vidéos 08 moi je suis pas compté mais
là c'est un accident
là c'était j'ai raison ben l'une des
vidéos ce sera des accidents aujourd'hui
regardez qu'est ce que ces changements
climatiques
oui c'est ça l'effet brûle après un
accident
ouais ils veulent un accident c'est le
mot accident est plus ici je pense à
l'émission les premières répondant oui
les premiers bains peut-être c'est un
héros dans ce cas-ci qu'on a vu aller
c'est est ce qu'on aimerait des
carambolages paraguay on parle de
carambolages lui ware en définitive je
crois que c'est les accidents ouais mais
il ya quelque chose qui revient souvent
du côté du mans les camions
ouais mais camions et poids l'eau sur
nos routes
alors pour nous il s'agit de faire deux
choses aujourd'hui de revoir ces
questions de sécurité des poids lourds
sur nos routes il ya beaucoup
d'accidents en ontario les statistiques
sont absolument renversante le niveau de
l'augmentation chose qu'on parlait de
25% d'augmentation l'an dernier entre
une période de six mois
c'est pas vraiment cas partout ce qui
est important de savoir c'est que c'est
un souci de première heure augmenter la
sécurité des transports d'affaires parce
que les camions sont très présents sur
nos routes
il ya le train de bien sûr mais quand on
veut faire des distances moyennes aux
quatre échevins c'est le camion tout à
fait nous céder l'existant distance
longue en france ce serait des distances
très très très longue pour nous sur les
moyens mais en tout cas et puis aussi
beaucoup de dote d'une forte demande
pour des camionneurs ce sont des gens
qui dans l'ensemble sont comme nous ils
vieillissent ce sont des baby boom tous
ici marca
ce sont des gens qui avancent en a
aujourd'hui dans certaines entreprises
que la moitié d'entre eux au québec par
exemple ont 50 ans et plus un tiers ont
plus de 60 ans donc il ya une demande
pour déjà qualifiés qui pourrait venir
par exemple l'extérieur voilà vu que la
politique d'immigration de certaines
provinces le permettent ne pointez pas
les provinces du tout s'accélère qu'il
ya eu des problèmes entre guillemets
horaires un taux aux etats-unis puis son
voyage il doit se faire aux états unis
comment est ce qu'on fait en ce moment
la bonne question
écoutez je vais vous montrer quelque
chose qui pour moi est très nettement
les sujets que j'aborde les missions que
j'amène à l'émission ce soin des sujets
très personnelle des des enfants ces
choses c'est toujours si je m'y
intéresse pas ça ça passe assez rare
ceux ci mettaient à ces accidents de
camions et la présence des camions parce
que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
poids lourds parce que moi je conduis
beaucoup et se trouvait donc très
souvent sur la route
voici ce qui s'est passé en chemin hier
ou avant-hier vers 11h30 regarde la
vidéo numéro 2 c'est le résultat
durant la nuit moi je suis passé par là
après juste au moment où il allait
ouvrir l'autoroute ça se passe au niveau
de la frontière de l'ontario du québec
est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour la vidéo
numéro 2 ouais ouais
très bien alors on va regarder ça
ensemble vous avez suivi les nouvelles
ou savait de quoi il est question
vidéo numéro 2 ça va ça vient très bien
ce qu'est ce que j'aime et d'armand ça
prend du temps mais ça va être bon alors
voilà c'est ces images-là sur la
principale autoroute canadienne l'autre
la plus achalandée au monde c'est la 406
l'a400m
elle devient la 20 au québec c'est là où
l'accident s'est produit une dame qui a
perdu la vie j'avais plein de camions et
je crois qu'elle dure qui se sont
retrouvés entre des camions comme on
comme écrasé un pc boîte c'est ça alors
qu'ailleurs c'est un camion qui a perdu
un rôle dans une courbe qui est quand
même assez connus ont volé les
camionneurs diminuer la vitesse normale
c'est un cas je sais que dans cette
société d'autoroutes souvent c'est pas
salé c'est mal ça l'est je le dis pas je
passe le cuir et les conditions
routières étaient particulièrement
difficile jusque là avec une clameur
c'est la façon de conduire
avaleur un jeu ya arrière et avec
beaucoup de glace dans la rue tu me
promener par l'autoroute 40 dans l'ouest
de l'île moi j'étais plutôt prudent
parce que je ne sais pas d'où il est
venu divers oui je compte juke-r la main
mais des cagnottes qui passe comme si
rien n'était tout à fait je sais pas
peut-être sont des contraintes
d'horaires il faut arriver
dodin à l'emploi pour livrer la
marchandise mais quand même assez
dangereux ils sont vraiment dans une loi
je me demande si c'est pas une culture
sont à des nouveaux conducteurs dans les
camions ou même les gens qui conduisent
sur la route dans leur voiture est-ce
qu'on était en train de perdre la
culture de savoir comment conduire en
hiver oui c'est une très bonne question
maryse si vous voulez on veut mettre de
côté des accidents parce qu'on veut
parler d'un métier qui n'est pas facile
mais qui est très précieux pour tout le
monde parce qu'on veut avoir ses
livraisons dans les 24 heures
c'est peut-être la solution est atteint
alors si vous avez activé la grosse
boule pendant que je diminue le niveau
de mon écoute à ce que je fais appel à
une spoliation français mais ça fait du
bruit
alors voici c'est la grosse boule
premier jeu il ya trois jeux l'émission
vous avez au total 100 boul au départ
d'édition vous perdez déroule à chaque
tour enfin vous le souhaite pas mais
c'est ce qui se passe alors première
premier tour 20 boules à perdre voici
selon une étude réalisée en 2016 par
l'alliance canadienne du camionnage il
manquerait 34000 camionneurs à ce moment
là au canada d'ici 2024
il ya en ce moment apparemment faudra
vérifier 300000 conducteurs de camions
au canada un accord combien sont des
femmes sur ce total combien sont des
femmes sur ces 3 5 millions pourcentage
bas je vais vous donner un deux voire
est-ce que c'est 3000 femmes
conductrices de camions sur 300 sur 300
mais acea
est ce que ces bébés 9000 femmes
conductrices de camions est-ce que c'est
ses 15000 conductrice sur 300 milles
jeudi les baies et c'est pas fini
aucun
pour qu'une femme enceinte ça c'est la
réponse que j'aime beaucoup
aucune de ces réponses je dirais une
hache mille vous dernier 9000 dont p oui
bah moi j'hésite entre les 3000 et
aucune de ces réponses vous être
réaliste je pense qu'il n'a pas obtenues
par un bon signe c'est peut-être un peu
plus égalitaire mais je pense que c'est
plus aucune de ces réponses ou ou 3000
je vais être positive
je vais dire 3003 du je vais te
rencontre a notamment joué à quinze
mille 15 mille marie-claude vous aussi
vous pouvez par mois auxquels elle ne
nous entend pas piloter un avion
non mais bon oui bonjour ce que vous
m'avez généralement les il n'y a pas
beaucoup de femmes qui prendraient ces
risques là donc c'est plus réaliste 3000
je trouve ça pas de penser à qui a
répondu à 3000 c'est vrai
voilà vous gardez vos boules en faire du
vin
si on a derrière notre invité sur skype
on va le salut et cegid bernard boulet
directeur général de camou route
monsieur goulet bonjour oui bordeaux
octobre est ce que vous avez fait
beaucoup de chemin pour venir nous
parler aujourd'hui où vous êtes resté à
la maison
non la bête sur l'est de montréal donc
c'est relativement de 60 pieds rapides
pour moi ce matin il est en sécurité
c'est très bien fait là je demandé
lorsqu'on a dit parce qu on a dit
beaucoup de choses nous on livre notre
opinion nos sentiments nos impressions
c'est notre travail la réalité par
rapport à ce qu'on a discuté les
demandes d'emploi la nécessité de
trouver des travailleurs commençons par
ça est ce qu'on la vit comme ça à
l'étranger ou venez ou postuler est ce
que si on peut le faire si on était
intéressé par exemple on est en france
si on veut venir travailler ici
est-ce que ça c'est du domaine du
possible où on sait faire rêver non
c'est du domaine du possible les mais ce
soir on ne peut pas savoir quel lieu
dieu tu sont des règles qui sont à
suivre
qu'on souhaitait un camion d'art
je sors de profession ou d'autres
professions au niveau des règles pour
l'immigration mais il voudrait que la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre est tellement
d'ampleur les cours des dernières années
maintenant effectivement les entreprises
font du recrutement l'international ou
en temps de les occulter des routiers
professionnels dont des gens
expérimentés et compétents
ce soit qui peuvent effectivement de se
joindre des soldes le haut la médaille
ici au québec pour répondre aux besoins
puisqu'on est vraiment l'impression de
hinrik leone je vous dirais les
statistiques les eaux leur troisième
trimestre selon canada il y avait au
moins plus de 3600 postes de conducteurs
de camions lors se soient vacants
uniquement le pauvre se sont compliquées
depuis trois mois auparavant il y en
avait quatre mille donc on atteint des
niveaux encore deux postes vacants
donc effectivement les voudraient la
main d'oeuvre de l'immigration mais ça
représente le laisser sur une solution
la problématique quels sont les pays
oui qui sont les plus intéressants pour
recruter des routiers comme on disait ne
soit pas je voudrais qu'elle libère des
entreprises ont beaucoup ciblées la
france
le centre autour je voudrais que tu fais
que du bout de la langue de travail
aulas au québec et en france
ça facilite l'intégration qu'avant je
voudrais faire l'essuie mais à l'échelle
canadienne les yeux de voudrais que dans
les provinces se sont anglophones les
l'ontario qu'on a vue plus technique les
troupes canadiennes démontré que peu de
leur faute ils s'étaient tous les pays
de l'asie du sud est qui étaient là ce
soir demain lire alors que côté du
québec m'ont laissé seul à la fin sur
l'algérie le maroc la tunisie comptait
lieu bassin krishna de soho d'attalens
qu'on cherche à tirer a dit ce monsieur
voulait y at il une stratégie en
particulier pour attirer une clientèle
plus jeune
dans ce secteur là parce qu'on constate
que la moyenne d'âge la danse et singh
content c'est des gens qui sont
relativement fatigué donc comment faire
en sorte que les jeunes s'intéressent à
ce secteur
ces défis il est vrai que c'est vraiment
difficile et c'est très difficile parce
que je voudrais tous les secteurs
d'activités économiques les enfants sont
en pénurie de main d'oeuvre donc les
jeunes ont vraiment grand choix dans le
fond de la profession de carrière on la
commence dès marquillies je voudrais que
pour la conduite d'un véhicule ou quand
on parle d'un camion il ya des règles du
code de la sécurité routière au québec
en sorte que les eaux conduire un camion
dont doit avoir cumulé le 30 6 mois
d'expérience de conduite donc trois ans
donc pour recruter des jeunes pour
souhaiter leurs ce soir continuité une
formation donc et qui seraient de niveau
secondaire donc trois ans conduire qu'à
l'issue le seul le jeune la jeune fille
ou le jeune garçon obtenu son permis de
conduire a ses raisons mais cela mène à
19 ans donc ça crée un problème je serai
systémique en lien avec la
réglementation au québec on a eu trois
grandes le programme enrichi à la
conduite d'un véhicule ou pour les 17 18
ans donc ça permet à des élèves en
continuité scolaire de s'inscrire à une
formation de 6 à 15 heures donc un des
pays en transport par camion donc les
jeunes ont accès via ce programme là la
conduite de véhicules aux dons qu'elles
y ait des règles particulières soient
pas gamme enrichie qui implique pas mal
du tout dans une entreprise je suivis
les évaluations de son comportement de
sa performance au volant également la
performance de l'entreprise en terme de
sécurité routière avec des centres de
formation veut aussi être est elle aussi
réfléchi impôts donc avec les deux
centres de formation l'élève est pris en
charge
libreville 6 pour faire une formation en
conduite de camions ça lui permet 18 ans
de construire en autonomie sur nous donc
élevé on peut imaginer un camion semi
remorque
vous pouvez y avoir au volant une jeune
fille ou un garçon de 18 ans qui conduit
façon autonome mais contenue dans un
programme enrichi
il est cette personne là bas les salles
et vraiment suivi ou une odeur si ce
raid
sa conduite jusqu'au moment où il va
rapidement avoir atteint 136 moins 2 ans
d'expérience de construire obtenu comme
toutes les autres conducteurs de camion
un permis définitif de glace par exemple
et au regard du nombre de poids lourds
impliqués dans les accidents de la
circulation
ces derniers temps est ce que vous
envisagez des remises en niveau des
formations supplémentaires pour pour ces
conducteurs là pour leur montrer la
meilleure façon de conduire en période
difficile
webb est tout à fait c'est les soldes
bon vieux quand mon goûter la commission
des partenaires du marché du travail la
déformation termes de formation continue
on va parler de ce sont deux des co éco
conduite des conduites sexuelles et la
conduite préventive donc on a développé
effectivement des formations qui sait ce
qu'ils s'adressent autant travailleurs
expérimentés que les nouveaux
conducteurs
donc comment avoir un comportement que
ce soit sécuritaire ce soit au volant
développer de bonnes habitudes de ce
sont des conduites pour être davantage
au niveau de la prévention donc pas en
compte un ensemble d'éléments qui ont
peut pas vous avez su relevé tout à
l'heure le bol la question des
intempéries avec les changements météo
mais comme on adapte notre conduite
comment vas t'appeler notre conduite on
est en milieu urbain on est sur le
réseau autoroutier en fonction du type
de véhicule que je lis la charge ce que
je suis léger où je suis très lourd les
donc tous ces facteurs l'homme et sont
pris en compte dans le cadre de ce sont
deux formations qui sont très populaires
les les gens seront entre son père et sa
petite laura avoir leur main mise à jour
des compétences
compte tenu de l'évolution des véhicules
de la réalité de la circulation
automobile ou sinon on réalise à quel
point ces complexes la question de la
mobilité et la congestion routière les
travaux de construction les championnes
des réalités crues de ce qu'on vit au
quotidien effectivement ces formations
là et on a roulé aussi adapté vraiment
milieu urbain on sait aussi que
l'acceptabilité sociale des villes kg
milieu urbain c'est devenu un enjeu donc
pour nous les lui aussi avant deux
formations qui se soit pour se souvenir
soutenir les conducteurs qui vont avoir
sonné
ok tu l'autoroute on arrive à entendre
milieu urbain sera nos quartiers
résidentiels industriels dont vous faire
des livraisons dans des quartiers
résidentiels d'une carte on pense aux
épiceries par exemple les supermarchés
on va avoir circulé sur des retours on
va rencontrer des clientèles vulnérables
nous aussi il ya lieu effectivement là
de ce sont deux entre deux formes et les
gens pour qu'ils soient d'abord quoi que
ce soit nécessairement davantage alerte
mais au moins leur donner des outils
pour dans un contexte davantage de
prévention pour les assurer la sécurité
vient d'examiner quelques instants de
nouveaux outils qui sont en train d'être
mis sur la route pour ainsi dire au
niveau de la sécurité parmi les choses
vous avez une question est en fait la
question c'était surtout sur le permis
de construire
moi je fais mes grands quand je suis
arrivé ici il n'y a fallu que la phase 1
2 fois le test
théorique et moi je pense que je connais
les règles qui est ce qu'il va voir des
facilités pour les gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur si ce qu'ils peuvent pas
rentrer pour faire dix ont un permis
moins compliqué à la voir c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire est pas la sacem
effectivement de la société de
l'assurance automobile du québec c'est
l'organisme qui est responsable au
niveau de l'émission que le contrôle des
permis de conduire il ya des ententes de
réciprocité et qui existent l'avait que
certains pays dont la france et pour les
deux raids encore des pays où il ya pas
d'attendre de risques possibles de
reconnaissance la mutuelle de la
validité des permis à ce moment-là bella
personnes quand elles arrivent ici ça
devienne qui tacle plus que lille est à
la case départ donc les comme tout autre
citoyen mais va devoir de passer à
travers les étapes obtenir un permis
d'apprenti la période probatoire de deux
ans avec son père me classe 5 soit
valide ses 36 mois donc pour une
personne qui était déjà expérimenté dans
un pays qui est pas reconnue et ça
devient les prix les effectivement les
sur le voudrait sur le site de la
société d'assurance automobile il ya
maintenant le on peut le faire d'une
façon interactive en indiquant de quel
pays on prévient il ce lundi que les
étapes sont à suivre en fonction de
l'existence d'une entente ou non avec le
pays d'origine
monsieur boulet je mens damas à notre
chef chef web
marie-claude de mettre en ligne les
vidéos numéro 3 maintenant j'espère vous
allez pouvoir saisir voir ces images ce
sont des mots le principe demeure le
même est ce que vous voyez des images en
ce moment je croyais et l'allier au oui
alors je pense que vous reconnaissez
facilement de quoi il est question un de
ces outils qui prennent place à bord
maintenant des camions est ce que c'est
obligatoire et qu'est ce que c'est
exactement ce qu'on voit et cela
lorsqu'on voit c'est le mot c'est qu'au
niveau des arts de service les seuls
leaders qui sont autorisés à la conduite
d'un véhicule lisant de service et de
repos les
jusqu'à maintenant les accords de
l'école se sont québec au canada les
gens vont contre les conducteurs une
réglementation donc un nombre limite de
reconstruire à chaque jour d'une
obligation de périodes de repos puis les
sociétés s'étale sur une semaine ou sur
deux semaines dépendamment du cycle les
dons qu'elle est jusqu'à maintenant elle
va les gens confie le sur ce soit sur un
document pepy les ordres de service le
son soit enregistré alors ce qu'on voit
les grands les l'aide d'une tablette
électronique
c'est un système qui permet
effectivement de rassembler
d'enregistrer les airs donc on parle de
deux systèmes le tarage stromae
électronique
ce sont des désordres de conduire donc
c'est fait vraiment temps réel
ça c'est vraiment lui vous aurez c'est
un outil qui sait ce qui fait en sorte
que de vos mac le consultant dans le
véhicule
il doit effectivement le maître cci il
dans son code
il met en marche donc lé les heures de
conduite sont son côté comptabilisé
d'une façon leur arrestation automatique
dont kelly on épure et dépendent à
l'autre de son d'une compilation le qui
fait le pari personne n'aurait qu'à sa
journée de travail
oui mais ce que vous avez parlé des
heures de conduite mais ce qu'il ya un
nombre d'heures obligatoires de repos
pour s'assurer que les camionneurs qui
s'assoit sécurité oui ce serait pour
éviter l'épuisement volant c'est ça
ouais je voudrais le bcd effectivement
les sur une période de soldes d'une
semaine maximum des fautes de conduite
le qui cessa de 60 à 70 heures de
conduite sur une période de sept jours
mais sur chaque période de 24 heures il
ya une obligation d'avoir un buteur
qu'on s'explique mois de repos on vous
pose l'explication là sur leur poésie
parce que je vais vous montrer la vidéo
numéro cap tout le monde au canada sait
de quoi il est question
à l'extérieur il faudra leur donner
quelques détails il s'agit d'un
conducteur de camion en saskatchewan au
mois d'avril dernier qui n'a pas
effectué son arrêt obligatoire au stop
ça se passe en saskatchewan et il a
frappé de plein fouet un camion enfin
camion un autobus qui comptait une toute
une équipe de hockey avec quelques
personnel additionnel
voici les personnes qui est maintenant
reconnue coupable et qui va connaître sa
sentence je pense je sais pas calmé
il est très bientôt alors qu'ils ont
voilà ça c'est une image que tous les
canadiens reconnaissent
voilà la scène s'est tiré de cbc news
corp fait qu'accéder ça se traduit très
bien en français alors besoin de faire
une image dessus et puis alors que
gaillard 1 to écoutez terry et u16
personnes treize personnes qui sont
mortes ou 15 15 personnes
puis plus que ça encore qui ont été
blessés mais qui dit hacker géniale de
la saskatchewan qui s'en allait vers un
match où on va voir les images de cette
équipe et ils sont pas tous décédés ce
qu'on va voir mais les 15 et 16 se
trouve dans cette image là où une partie
d'entre eux se trouvent là dedans voir
ça s'en vient la fin des vidéos écouter
cet homme là on l'a appris ça cette
semaine qu'il avait commis soixante dix
infractions aux règlements fédéraux et
provinciaux dans les jours précédant la
tragédie notamment quand il remplissait
son carnet de bord à la main avec mon
crayon à mine quand j'en ai un ici je
pense ici avec un crayon à mine web il
mais il ya visiblement il n'avait pas le
carnet de bord électronique est ce que
ces pauvres c'est tout c'est obligatoire
où seuls les pas ces facteurs facultatif
ou quoi bon c'est pas obligatoire
ce souk el had à salé aux états unis
c'est sûr maintenant il ya de plus en
plus d'entreprises là ce canadien qui
adoptent enregistrant d'abord
électronique et maintenant du moment
qu'on fait du transport transfrontalier
on va vers les états unis les les heures
de conduite conflit au québec si on
traverse aux états unis mais son odeur
ou au canada mais sont aussi compilé le
lire on démarre pas le look book
électronique dans le jargon carton à vis
de la frontière lilesa qu'on a fait
avant sont aussi comptabilisé donc elle
est de plus en plus d'entreprises qui
l'utilisent
il y avait que leurs boucles
électroniques mal et les sauces et
combos de la compilation des hardes ce
soit de conduite sont faits de repos
mais c'est aussi un outil le qui permet
aussi la lavande serait le monitoring
qu'elle se soit complet des déplacements
du véhicule qu'il peut y avoir de l'âge
localisation on sait où le véhicule
s'est arrêté on peut le suivre en temps
réel en termes de quelle est la vitesse
et puis il ya toutes sortes de
dispositifs aussi maintenant qui
s'ajoutent les ou suivent-ils du
conducteur dont entre autres il y était
les freinages brusques que
l'accélération les est ce que le
véhicule de tanguy est ce qu on a fait
des changements de voie de façon
agressive
est-ce qu'on a respecté les limites de
vitesse ce soin d'attention des zones où
on était donc un ensemble d'éléments
maintenant c'est ça qui viennent à la
fois d'israël et de superviser contrôler
la performance conçu par au volant mais
ça peut être aussi d'un outil qui va
venir se sont accompagnées et d assister
le conducteur et électroniques deee on
va regarder les images de la vie
quotidienne à montréal en hiver avec du
verglas avec la neige on voit à quoi les
gens à l'extérieur auront à quoi
ressemble notre cette belle ville le gnv
là en importance au pays
ouais ça c'est une belle journée on ne
patine pas regarder un camion rouge
regarder ce camion rouge
il fait que tourner la roue et la même
photo se trouve juste de l'autre côté
c'est vous qui avez pris ce nom se
prennent en main non non non je passe
pas mon temps au coin de la rue plus
maintenant
alors écoutez ça là on il a évité
l'accident il a évité l'écraser
peut-être un piéton qui aurait été coin
de la rue en attendant de traverser le
feu moi je considérais qu'il allait à
une vitesse normale et ben non je les
lui tourner la caméra je peux passer
quand j'étais très surpris de le voir
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose pour
éviter pour aider les camionneurs à
négocier certains virages
c'est les conducteurs automobiles comme
nous on est assistée on a de la
technique ça n'en plus finir
est ce qu'il ya une nouvelle technologie
à bord des camions qui peuvent aider à
la conduite
oui les deux voudrait dans 60 connaître
le code est attendu à lille de vierges
de moi je pense que jos au niveau de
chargement
demain quelle est la répartition du
poids et est peut-être là tout à fait
particulier sur un côté de la remorque
il devait y avoir notre charge leur est
excessif donc la prime abord il ya une
réglementation le prévoit au niveau de
mon appel mais ses dimensions donc
comment répartir le poids au niveau des
tissus à prime abord que chargement de
fois conforme sécuritaire mais il existe
effectivement des housses et fantine
renversement de maintenant qui vont
venir ce soit encore le cas où le
véhicule de une bombe serait sur le
point se renverser ben ali il pourrait y
avoir le rehaussement du niveau du
rendement moteur ou du système de
freinage les une opération sous le par
dans l'ordinateur qui d'abord qui
viendrait le site soit corrigé la course
nature de cession du véhicule mais les
mais avant d'arriver à utiliser le
système vraiment le dréau au préalable
lorsque des mesures de prévention est
importante à prendre ou ne vous la
qualité du chargement en ce sens premier
du personnel au niveau de la conduite
sont éteints vitesse excessive une
manoeuvre virage série balle et je
voudrais qu'elle attire versement
vraiment une un système de dernier
recours pour d'enfants rappeler c'est
une mauvaise conduite
mais sur quatre immenses des outils qui
peuvent venir aider dans un coffre fort
suisse où il revend latéral qui aurait
vraiment touché la remorque donc pour
éviter le renversement
mais c'est que ça fait des outils mais
dans ce cas là mais je pense que des de
bonne conduite préventive au réseau made
in usa
monsieur vous laisse comme au moment de
procéder au chargement du camion il ya
comme une instance qui veille à ce que
la charge soit équitablement réparties
dans le camion
oui ce seul domaine où le bon québec ont
un contrôle routier québec
donc elle est lé ministère des
transports ce soir à bienne
règlement qui permet effectivement qui
va devenir la question les charges
compris met à l'intérieur notre une
remorque en fonction du nombre d'essieux
le sac avoir trouvé sous la remorque
donc est lié le x doivent être répartis
entre na compte là dessus
le camion tracteur en avant donc si l'on
sonne de 3 essieux le ce la roma donc
elle le poids doit être répartie
équitablement là ce sont fonction de la
réglementation donc c'est une
réglementation très sévère on voit le
long des routes des sceaux ce qu'on
appelle communément les balances donc
elle est gâtée film les feux clignotants
sont allumés bas on voit les la série
camions qui vont passer à la balance
ils iront voir tableau le titre
d'indication électronique doit lire ça
sans même suivre comme s'ils étaient de
le taux de change la chine et ses pales
des taux de change c'est le nom de
scellier le poids par essieu meskiana
suffisamment de ces endroits où on peut
peser les camions et est ce que la
plupart des camions
elle s'arrête sur le web est une
obligation les je voudrais que pour
l'expéditeur ou de transporter les
salaires le transporteur va s'assurer
les à partir devant lequel et les
marchandises que j ai transportés
quel est le poids c'est sa
responsabilité de saison d'avant
chargement qui est conforme
il est qu'on arrive à la balance et pour
faire confirmer qu'effectivement qu'on
respecte les réglementations et au wat
de pas l'occasion des véhicules sont
stationnés où on fait un déchargement
parce qu'effectivement on ne respecte
rien dans quel qu'est ce qui arrive aux
camionneurs qui qui n'arrête pas la
pesée oui j'ai vu ça assez souvent
j'arrête pas la bonne question dans un
cas comme celui là bas les il ya des
véhicule d'interception bien les espoirs
à l'heure d'aller seul programme
d'évaluation qui existent aussi leur
ouvrent leurs propriétaires exploitants
de véhicules aux puits au psy pour le
conducteur de véhicule aux belles
hausses iliad est l'équivalent des
points du des petites sommes qui peuvent
être assorties de ces soldats morts pour
avoir respecté les effectivement de
postes de contrôle à peu il valoir une
suspension de son permis
une compagnie sion devant la commission
des transports du québec avec une
obligation formation l'obligation de le
conformiste et ses bas parfois quand je
crois va vouloir passer passer pour être
sous la halle
non inutile pour le bénéfice de tous
écoutent et immoraux monsieur voulait il
va falloir ranger le camion c'est comme
avec jacques attali garçons ont arraché
nos camions parce que c'était très
agréable de pouvoir enfin vous parler de
ces questions là qui nous touche tous
parce qu'on voit tous des camions dans
les situations problématiques et ont
saisi des squats ou ne pas rester dans
leur langue le mans à s'écouter cédé
plus forcée des plus gros faut faire
attention et plus collectivement prendre
leurs responsabilités pour une meilleure
sécurité
ça je pense que on pourrait présenter
des multiples vidéos ici de camionneurs
qui filme des automobilistes les coupant
ou jouer à des jeux de dangereux
dangereux
oui et complètement malboum à des beats
débile alors ça faut dire écoutez merci
beaucoup monsieur boulet puis continuer
le bon travail sur le bon rythme et
c'est alors si ils veulent la grosse
boule c'est le président j'ai lu tion ça
c'est pas de lumière pour vous dire
d'arrêter à la pesée attention on va
peser on va évaluer vos connaissances
générales 30 ball à perdre pour le
deuxième jeu en 2018
la rémunération horaire moyenne au
canada était de 29 dollars s'il ne fait
plus que 29 dollars tous stables l'année
pour les camionnettes ou le mans au
corum hommes et femmes tout le monde en
2018 enfin 29 dollars chez les hommes
pardonnez-moi de 125 $ seulement chez
les femmes c'est la rémunération moyenne
dites moi quels étaient leurs 2018 la
rémunération horaire moyen d'un
conducteur de camion vous avez choix et
s 15 $ par semaine à pâques allemand je
suis sur 20 dollars par heure c'est 25
dollars par heure ou d aucune de ces
réponses
aucune scène
même chose ici aucune de ces agences 25
$ 25 de leur stage
oui mais avec l'antenne vous pourrez
vous afficher sur la caméra
moi je n'aime pas mal vous faites ça je
vais essayer de me brancher avec moi je
dois dire que mes collègues et d aucune
de ces réponses
aucune de ces réponses et noté alors
levé la main si vous avez dit aucune de
ces réponses
alors la réponse vous avez perdu votre
en boule away qui a répondu 25,20
dollars non ou attendez whaou et la
diversité moi j'ai dit médecin
ouais 20 $ ou 13 ou 15 $ qui est 15 ou
20 $
moi je vous remercie à 25 personnes et
les mains du risque écoutez au canada
les camionneurs de route de longue
distance on va les appeler comme ça qui
travaille 60 heures par semaine en
moyenne qui fait dessus 600 kilomètres
chaque jour
ça équivaut un salaire horaire
approximative de 20 $ beaucoup et ceux
qui font les petits trajets en ville
c'est moins le salaire minimum au québec
c'est combien mais normalement c'est
plus que ça oui alors à la moitié il ya
plein de responsabilité faut qu'il
s'arrête cela c'est l'équivalent de 13 à
15 dollars c'est pas beaucoup mais pas
beaucoup d'anti moment pas amusant mais
ça se termine bien écouter une histoire
qui se termine bien on aime bien ça fait
ça se passe dans l'autre partie du pays
là où en principe c'est dangereux de
conduire un camion éléments dans les
rocheuses on a notre vidéo pour vous le
montrer ça s'appelle on appelait ça cris
de panique vous allez voir on va avoir
du son un peu que ce soit clair et je
veux le faire jouer en boucle si c'est
pas faire pour vous ça se passe dans les
rocheuses sur un camionneur qui voit un
autre
tu as peut être dépassé oui mais voilà
sur la route quoi est ce que vous voyez
vous avez vous talons qu'est ce que vous
faites là le camionneur la bonne chose
il s'est assez c'est assez
écoutez il ya été au bord dé tomber
c'est possible mais c'est parce que le
problème c'est que dans beaucoup
d'endroits dans les rocheuses par
exemple c'est que les routes on a des
routes qui se rencontrent c'est à dire
qu'on va dans un sens et dans l'autre il
ya des cendres ont fait dépasser mais
normalement à une courbe
on ne devrait pas dépasser mais pas des
premiers mois capable d'avoir plus
l'éloignement la troupe ça puisque c'est
ce qu'on a le vrai que lorsqu'on est à
dire que la lie la glace ben ouais c'est
pas évident malheureusement ce qu'on
apprend est ce qu'on fait sur le terrain
il ya tout un fossé et tout devrait être
l'image la semaine je répond par oui ou
par non à vos questions weedon aucun
responsable n'ont pas cessé alors c'est
la vidéo de 0,7
on la met en attente c'est la réponse à
la question quelle est l'image de la
semaine selon vous quelle est l'image la
semaine se passe au canada
ça se passe au canada tandis que je
réfléchisse oui ça se passe au canada
dumas s'est il ya un rapport avec des
animaux n'ont rien perdu
d'animaux jour là il ya souvent des
animaux dans nos images est-ce que c'est
politique
non c'est pas politiquement
polytechnique ya eu un hic
oui est-ce que c'est dans le domaine
culturel
est-ce que non parce que c'est au québec
non c'est dans la même zone que l'on a
vu la vidéo du canard qu'il a peur sas
dans la même zone
[Musique]
c'est un accident c'est un traître qui a
déraillé
on montre les images ce sera et c'est
pas souvent ça se produit ce histoire
avec ans à quand un train déraille je
vous dis que ça fait la manchette parce
que les dégâts sont épouvantables
hu ce point de faire parler
d'environnement et sujet ouverture de
l'émission c'était oui donc on travaille
sur votre subconscient voir si les
forces et à paron qu'on connaît
maintenant la raison il y avait un des
deux freins du train qui avait mal été
appliquées ou pas appliquées il était
dans une pente et plus grand ou en train
est parti six courses folles voilà sa
seconde passe du côté d'un combo
britannique voici les trois personnes
décédées à un jeune à prendre si un gars
avec beaucoup d'expérience et le
responsable combative le jeune homme à
votre droite ou à votre gauche l'a fait
triste ouais ça c'était malheureux c'est
à la fois très canadien parce que c'est
les rocheuses et c'est le défi de
traverser leur chose en train c'est pas
facile c'est faux taxi l'histoire du
canada aussi et puis et malheureusement
les accidents ça fait partie de la vie
aussi d'avoir des desks passe à
l'occasion chacun chacune il s'agit de
composer avec des prêts pour la dernière
partie plaisir oui je vais faire le
bilan à savoir où on en est j'en ai 50
bon vouvray 50 ans bull
maryse 50 comme moi on n'a pas non mais
j'étais assange avait généré libyen
réponse à la première question alors
soixante dix insa wade chez o2 première
l a50 devait pas participer à la
première danse et aubin j'ai participé
sans vous dire mais j'ai perdu je la
hais ce qu'on peut vous voir participer
mais c'est fait le plein de caméras a
coûté très cher moi je tiens voilà alors
là boldak aux boules voisins à perdre
je ne sais pas si je vais apporter ce
avait abusé la dernière question je vais
pas comment se nomme c'est red rose les
voir commencer comment se nomme le site
web qui se targue d'être au québec la
référence numéro un pour les camionneurs
ya rien site web qui fait beaucoup de
publicité qui fait beaucoup de tapage
jeu nous sommes le numéro 1 en référence
pour les camions est ce que c'est un
facebook ou juste un citoyen c'est un
vrai site web liquidateur un vrai site
web vous allez voir quand je vous donne
l'adresse on va pouvoir
alors vous avez le choix est ce que
c'est à toi que tu as quebec.com est ce
que c'est ça est ce que ces bébés
transport 53 points comme 53 53 pieds
c'est la longueur des drm pour moi ou
est ce que c'est c'est gros vite point
qu c3 transport s'avère plus sa valeur
très québécois semaine dernière
je vais prendre mes jambes moi je pense
je suis allé pour le premier parce que
j'ai pas peut-être que dans l'univers
des trois que on aime bien partant jake
les noms mais là au québec la loi ça ne
remet pas non dits et addiction alors la
loi du pointu c'est ce qui motive et que
je voulais ce que je veux c'est du passé
c'est pas vrai je mangeais pas répondu
mais avec nous apparaît tendre avec vous
à aider ses potes et moi j'allais dire
quand on veut juste un bon alors c'est
passé à la bonne réponse c'est on peut
aller voir ça si vous avez tout à fait
mais c'est à troc stock quebec.com les
soucis euros alors qu'il rapporte la
joute aujourd'hui benjamin ben eliezer
alors on va les voir sur le site vous
allez voir il s'en passe des choses des
annonces à fès le camionneur ouais il ya
d'autres sites là mais eux se targue
d'être la référer la ja s'est pas
vérifiée j'avais une attaque dire il est
dit il arrive qu'on ait je ne sais pas
mais je batte de doute mais je ne
mangeais pas vérifié radio canada n'a
pas vérifié d'accord je dis ça c'est
bien sûr la mairesse qui n'a pas une
atteinte au règlement sur l'affichage au
québec
bonjour fiche sur seb a coûté
l'antisionisme sur internet j'ai ce sens
l'espace public la semaine prochaine
[Rires]
c'est ça voilà on ira voir la loi on l'a
on la laissait alors voyez s'en passe
des choses et puis j'en ai bu et là vous
remarquerez qui a pas beaucoup de photos
de femmes malgré qu'il ya trois
conductrices au canada 1 % de toutes les
bourses en image de femme ouais en moins
bon voilà et surtout des camions pas
beaucoup de camionneurs vous allez
remarquer probablement le transport
automatique que c'est un camionneur
c'est que ça s'en vient aussi on n'a pas
parlé de ça pour bientôt
non je pense que c'est à dieu il ya
c'est tellement de responsabilités
associées aux transports
le problème c'est les assureurs c'est
vrai ouais ils veulent pas rentrer là
dedans car quand on n'a pas de camion
autonomes au québec non non non non même
pas les autos en fait il y en a des
heureux la cape la capacité d'être
autonome
mais ils veulent tous pour le moment il
ya beaucoup de choses à revoir avant
lancé ça marie-claude on vous remet à la
caméra vous revenez à la caméra c'est
une photo de groupe dont on a besoin
évidemment pour faire nos adieux à la
caméra numéro deux et puis tellement
merci d'être venu avec nous pour jouer
et vous informer sur tout ça m'a
chamboulée
ouais merci à monsieur boulet pour 7,7
me c'est quoi la bouteille de champagne
et les boules parce que ces nounous
studio ah oui après mais il faudra pas
compter la flore attend pendant quatre
mois ben va
[Musique]